car safety Advocates are warning about a
potential risk from electric vehicles as
automakers roll out bigger and heavier
EVS there's growing concern that extra
weight of those batteries could result
in extra risk to other drivers and
pedestrians in a collision especially
from electric trucks and SUVs Chris Van
Cleave spoke with the chair of the NTSB
about those concerns
crash tests show electric vehicles hold
up well in a collision the extra weight
from their batteries helped better
protect the people inside but safety
Advocates worry the extra hundreds and
sometimes thousands of pounds present a
potential growing danger to other
drivers it's great that we are focused
on air quality but we are not focused on
safety with these vehicles National
Transportation safety board chair
Jennifer hamandy if you think about an
impact and a crash with a lighter
vehicle with a pedestrian it's going to
have a much different outcome terribly
tragic is there a concern that as people
switch to EVS that you see deaths on the
roads go up absolutely it could this
Crash Test shows what happens when a
sedan is hit by an SUV weighing nearly a
thousand pounds more the smaller car
suffers noticeably more damage why does
that extra weight make a difference the
mass matters and it's simple laws of
physics Raul arbolize from the Insurance
Institute for Highway Safety the crowd
for the other vehicle when you are
heavier is going to be more severe GMC's
electric Hummer can go 0 to 60 in
roughly three seconds while weighing
more than nine thousand pounds over
three thousand pounds more than GMC's
full-size pickup and its battery alone
comes in at about 2 900 pounds roughly
the same as a Toyota Corolla the
electric Ford F-150 weighs up to 2500
pounds more than its gas-powered sibling
and rivian's pickup weighs in around 7
100 pounds while the average vehicle on
the roads today weighs closer to 4 300.
that difference matters a 2011 study
found even a one thousand pound
difference results in a 47 percent
increase in the likelihood a crash turns
deadly I have a a 7 000 pound vehicle
hitting a 4 000 pound SUV the impact on
that smaller vehicle is going to be
quite significant it is going to be a
more severe crash with more intrusion
and higher levels of injury so
it's acknowledged that weight is only
one factor in a crash and while EV sales
are surging they still make up only a
small fraction of the number of total
vehicles on the roads so injury and
crash data is limited in a statement the
trade group representing the Auto
industry says safety is a top priority
adding automakers continue to test
develop and integrate breakthrough
safety Technologies like automatic
emergency braking that help save lives
and prevent injuries Tech technology
already common in EVS Federal Regulators
are now moving to require collision
avoidance systems in all new vehicles
gas or electric the government says it
would save 360 lives a year while
reducing injuries by at least 24
thousand we saw a collision avoidance
technology stopped this nearly 5 000
pound electric Genesis SUV on a test
track
technology helping balance out bulked up
batteries for CBS mornings I'm Chris Van
Cleef in Rutgersville Virginia